[Music]
et's got new details about TJ Holmes and
Amy robach's secret relationship this is
a competitive bunch and we're the
married GMA anchors stand with their
spouses keeping the romance alive in any
relationship well maybe it's a challenge
these days just a little bit sometimes
right here's what we know it's something
we've never done on GMA before and we've
done a lot here the Daily Mail broke the
romance news on Wednesday publishing
pics of Amy and TJ packing on the PDA
all over New York in recent weeks
meanwhile that morning it was business
as usual for TJ at the 9 A.M anchor desk
uh yes Roblox is not here Dr Ashton not
here stuck with me folks oh just take it
in eat it up right tonsil
um but yes those two are on the side but
they are working today the episode was
likely taped taped for the male blasted
out the story so no mention of it on air
but following the reports a source tells
E.T the romance has been going on in
secret for quite some time we will spare
you America all right still it's not
known when these two went from
colleagues to something more though the
mail reports the turn happened in June
when the pair were in the UK together to
cover the Queen's Platinum Jubilee this
is the Platinum party at the palace
thank you our source also notes Amy and
TJ have kept it professional on set even
when The Vibes are fun and sometimes
flirty
he always gets into the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
as for their Partners we've learned both
TJ and Amy split from their spouses
though we don't have a timeline was not
easy and sometimes it still isn't easy
Amy's married to 90s heartthrob Andrew
shoe he played Billy Campbell on Melrose
Place
something that makes you happy then you
deserve it Andrew and I are in our
second marriage we have a blended family
we have step children it's tough to have
two playbooks you have to have one
Playbook he brought so much love and
structure and joy and heart to our
family uh it's really been a journey and
since 2010 TJ's been married to Marley
fibig an attorney who's also chief of
staff at Jay-Z's Rock Nation they share
a daughter and TJ's dad to two kids from
a previous relationship okay we talked
about this you weren't supposed to say
that over on their socials both cleaned
house wiping their Instagram accounts
but before deleting her insta eagle-eyed
fans took note Amy's wedding rings have
been absent since September hey good
morning America on this very
unproductive work day at the office and
we're hearing the office romance is no
fling with another source telling E.T
that TJ and Amy grew closer while
co-hosting gma's third hour We're All
lucky to be here and apparently the
coupling is no surprise to co-workers
who've witnessed their special bond over
the year years that's true it's like you
know your marriage is like a plant you
have to water it every day it's just a
marriage segment or a landscaping
segment
[Music]